Transcriber:
In 1995, a fellow named Chris Klebba
decided to open a gym
in his hometown of Northville, Michigan.
Fitness had changed his life,
and he wanted others
in small-town Michigan
to have the same experience.
But the problem with gyms
is they can be intimidating.
It's the ultimate irony.
You go to a gym to get in shape,
but if you're out of shape,
you feel like you need
to get in shape just to show up.
That's why as many as 50 percent
of gym members quit within the first year,
which is fine if you open
a gym in New York or LA
with millions of people.
But in a small town,
you might simply run out of customers.
Now many gyms try to solve this problem
by making it difficult to quit.
So now not only am I feeling guilty
about not going to the gym,
but I’m stuck paying 100 dollars a month,
and I’m still not getting any thinner.
But Chris decided
to do something different.
Chris decided to invest in his workers.
He hired overly helpful,
overly friendly employees
who at any moment were eager to step in
and help you learn
how to use a piece of equipment
without making you feel
like you're being judged.
The idea was for
the 55-year-old mom or dad,
who’d never been
to a gym before in their lives,
to feel welcome
and comfortable immediately.
Now my question
as a private equity investor is:
Could this really be profitable?
There's an old joke about a man
who's had too much to drink
looking for his keys under a streetlight.
A cop comes by and offers to help
and asks where he thinks he lost them.
"In the park," comes the response,
"but I'm looking here
because the light's better."
That's a little how we investors
look at companies today.
We know that value at companies
is driven by people,
but we focus on short-term profit
because it's so much easier to measure.
I’ve worked in and around
private equity for 25 years
on six continents,
and I've seen this error in thinking
again and again and again.
In private equity,
we buy companies and seek to improve them
so we can sell them at a profit.
But very often that improvement
comes in the form of cutting costs,
especially labor costs.
Private equity employs
roughly nine million people
and has cut over a million jobs
in the past decade.
Too often we ask a company
for their org chart
just to figure out who is getting fired.
Now I think investors should take pride
for helping to make companies lean,
but I'm worried that we
may have done our job too well
and are now at risk
of starving companies of the people
that they need to be successful.
So the big opportunity for investors,
for executives and for you
is to create rather than cut good jobs.
Creating good jobs is now the focus
of my work as a social impact investor.
But to create good jobs,
you first need a definition of a good job,
which was surprisingly hard to find.
Spreadsheets and numbers are comforting,
but people are complicated,
which is why impact investing
can sometimes feel squishy.
Good for the soul, perhaps,
but risky for the pocketbook.
But my partners and I work at a company
that prides itself
on using data to solve problems.
So we spent the last two years
looking at all the academic research,
reading all the case studies.
We interviewed human capital experts
and surveyed workers
across hundreds of companies.
And from that work, we developed
a common sense definition of a good job,
one that correlates
with worker productivity
and helps us to build better companies.
So here it is.
A good job is where a worker,
one, is fairly treated.
Two, has a promising future.
Three, feels psychologically safe.
And four, has a sense of purpose.
Now by this definition,
only about a third of jobs today
qualify as good jobs.
But that's where data-driven
impact investing can help.
By putting hard numbers
to each of these conditions,
we can score each job
at the companies we invest in
and then work to improve the number
of good jobs at these companies.
So let's go through each of these
four conditions in turn,
and as we do, think
about the place where you work.
How does it measure up?
If the answer is "not good," don't worry,
you can help point your company
in the right direction.
So here we go.
Number one, a worker is fairly treated.
Now we spend roughly
a third of our adult lives working.
So whether you work
at Marshall's or Microsoft,
you want your employer
to pay you fairly for all that time.
But many investors see worker pay
as a zero-sum game.
Whatever a company gives to workers
must somehow come at our expense,
which is why when Home Depot
announced early in COVID
that they would be offering danger pay
and making investments in worker safety,
they saw their market value
crash by billions of dollars.
But our research found over 100 studies
that show that appropriate incentives,
attractive benefits
like retirement accounts and health care
and things like flexible schedules
more than pay for themselves
through improved productivity,
higher retention, lower hiring costs.
Home Depot itself is a company
that's built on the idea
of providing better service to customers
by employing experts on its shop floors.
People who have seen your problem before
because they've worked
in home repair and construction,
and they can help you to fix it better.
Now Home Depot is thriving today
thanks to its investment in workers.
Now fair pay is a critical,
critical thing,
but it's not the only thing that matters.
Which brings us to our second condition:
a promising future.
Fast food restaurants
not only pay low wages,
they also offer very little
in terms of learning and growth,
which is why their employees quit
after six to 12 months on average.
Think about that the next time you get
rude service at the drive-thru window.
But training and career path
can help to solve this riddle.
Restaurants like
Tender Greens in California
and Boloko in Boston
offer training to their low-wage workers
that qualifies them for management roles.
So you might start out as a dishwasher
earning 12 bucks an hour
and then with the right training,
you can become a restaurant manager
in a matter of months,
making nearly three times that much.
Now the prospect of tripling your wage
is a powerful motivator.
And the data shows that workers
are much more loyal and dedicated
when they feel that their company
is helping them to build a career.
Our third condition, psychological safety,
should be a fairly obvious one.
Think of the best boss you've ever had,
the one that motivated you
to go above and beyond at work.
I bet that person was a listener.
Because the modern workplace
is increasingly a place
of communication and collaboration.
But many workers find it difficult
or risky to speak up.
Professor Amy Edmondson of Harvard
has studied this issue
in government, nonprofits and companies
and found that most people's
first instinct is to self-protect.
Let's face it, life's too short
to correct your boss's mistake
if you think you might
get fired as a result.
Not speaking up is invisible,
but it can cost the company
valuable ideas.
It can squander employee talent or worse,
it can put customers or employees
at physical risk.
Google found from its quest
to create the perfect team
that the most important ingredient
was not the people involved
but rather the team's overall willingness
to share and listen.
It also found that great teams
don't hide from their mistakes,
but rather embrace them
as opportunities for learning
and to add to the overall IQ
of their companies.
Which brings us to purpose.
It's a lot easier to share
and listen to others
if you and your colleagues
feel passionately about your work.
But do you feel passionately
about the idea of going to work each day
for the sole purpose
of maximizing shareholder value
for investors you've never met?
It's just not a very energizing idea.
Humans, unlike machines, want to feel
connected to a higher purpose.
They want to feel proud and useful.
And fortunately, most companies
out there do exist for a reason.
But it can be hard to tell
when so many of their mission statements
read like they were generated by a robot.
I actually used an online
mission statement generator for this talk
to see what would come back.
"The mission of my TED talk
is to offer smart insights with empathy,
care and thoughtfulness."
Not bad for a computer.
But a good mission statement is more
than just nice words on a PowerPoint.
A good mission statement can be
the most distilled form of strategy,
the guiding light for a company
and its employees.
That fitness chain I mentioned earlier,
Impact Fitness,
has a very clear mission
to offer health through fitness
in underserved communities,
and they're deadly serious about it.
The founder, Chris, likes to repeat
that mission at company meetings.
Most gym owners would be thrilled
if their customers never showed up,
so long as they keep paying
the monthly bill.
But Chris wants people to show up
at workout in his gyms and get healthier.
That's why he not only tracked gym usage,
but tied it to executive pay.
The company has gone
from strength to strength,
growing from that single gym
in Northville, Michigan,
to now over three dozen gyms
across small-town Michigan,
Indiana and now Canada.
And it's done so in a way
that their employees
have every reason to be proud of.
It's an old corporate chestnut
that our employees
are our most valuable asset.
Today those words ring as hollow
as the automated voice,
telling us how important our call is
when we've been on hold for 10 minutes.
(Laughter)
But fortunately, creating good jobs
isn't rocket science.
These four conditions: fair treatment,
a promising future,
psychological safety and purpose
are relatively easy to track and improve.
And to do that, though,
requires investors and executives
to work together.
Because too often well-meaning CEOs
are cut short by short-term
oriented investors
and the boards that represent them.
But I believe with a better measure
of good jobs and the associated benefits,
investors will support
more investments in workers.
Because who wouldn’t
want to create good jobs
if you're creating more valuable
companies at the same time?
And our research shows that companies
with a higher proportion of good jobs
grow faster and are more profitable.
They attract better talent
and are more innovative.
Investors ignore this issue at their peril
because in today's economy,
good jobs aren't just good for society,
they're good business.
Thank you.